>>> WE WELCOME YOU TO "CBS THIS
MORNING" WITH SERIOUS NEWS.
>> WE DO.
WE BEGIN WITH A NEW WAVE OF
ISRAELI ATTACKS AFTER THE
DEADLIEST DAY SO FAR IN THE
LATEST CONFLICT BETWEEN ISRAEL
AND HAMAS.
ISRAELI FORCES CONTINUED TO
HAMMER GAZA OVERNIGHT, AND
THERE'S NO END IN SIGHT.
>> THESE ATTACKS COME AFTER AT
LEAST 42 PEOPLE WERE KILLED
THERE YESTERDAY, INCLUDING
CHILDREN.
ISRAEL'S PRIME MINISTER,
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU, SAYS HE
WANTS HAMAS TO PAY A HEAVY PRICE
FOR FIRING THOUSANDS OF ROCKETS
INTO ISRAEL, AND HE SAYS HE
GRIEVES FOR ALL CIVILIANS WHO
HAVE DIED.
IMTIAZ TYAB IS IN EAST JERUSALEM
WHERE THE VIOLENCE FLARED UP
MORE THAN A WEEK AGO.
GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: EVERYONE, GOOD
MORNING.
YOU'RE RIGHT, I'M HERE IN EAST
JERUSALEM.
AND YOU CAN SEE BEHIND ME THESE
HUGE CONCRETE BARRICADES WHICH
ISRAELI POLICE HAVE SET UP.
REALLY WHAT THEY DO IS SERVE TO
SEVER PALESTINIAN NEIGHBORHOODS
FROM EACH OTHER.
ALL OF WHICH, OF COURSE, REALLY
JUST KEEPS TENSIONS REALLY
ENFLAMED AS ISRAEL CONTINUES TO
BOMB GAZA.
OVERNIGHT, DOZENS OF ISRAELI AIR
STRIKES POUNDED THE GAZA STRIP
AS FIGHTER JETS CONTINUED TO
SMASH NEIGHBORHOODS, THOUGH
ISRAEL INSISTS THEY ARE SURGICAL
STRIKES ON HAMAS TARGETS.
6-YEAR-OLD SUSIE IS PULLED FROM
THE RUBBLE OF WHAT WAS HER HOME
AFTER BEING TRAPPED FOR SEVEN
HOURS.
HER MOTHER AND FOUR SIBLINGS
WERE ALL KILLED IN THE ISRAELI
STRIKE.
RIYAD ESHKUNTANA IS HER FATHER.
HE SAYS, "I WAS FILLED WITH ALL
THE ANGER OF THE UNIVERSE, BUT
WHEN I HEARD THAT ONE OF MY
DAUGHTERS WAS ALIVE, I THANKED
GOD."
THE EVISCERATION OF SOME OF
GAZA'S TALLEST TOWER BLOCKS BY
ISRAELI FIGHTER JETS HAVE BEEN
CAUGHT ON LIVE TELEVISION.
LIKE THERIS BUILDING THAT HOUSE
FOREIGN MEDIA INCLUDING THE
"ASSOCIATED PRESS."
JOURNALISTS WERE WARNED TO LEAD
AHEAD OF THE STRIKE BEING CALLED
AN ASSAULT ON PRESS FREEDOM.
SPEAKING TO CBS' "FACE THE
NATION," ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU DEFENDED THE
ATTACK.
>> AN INTELLIGENCE OFFICE FOR
THE PALESTINIAN TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION HOUSED IN THAT
BUILDING THAT PLOTS AND
ORGANIZES THE TERRORIST ATTACKS
AGAINST ISRAELI CIVILIANS.
SO IT'S A PERFECTLY LEGITIMATE
TARGET.
>> Reporter: DESPITE THE
ENORMOUS DEVASTATION ACROSS
GAZA, HAMAS IS CONTINUING ITS
ROCKET CAMPAIGN AGAINST ISRAEL
CAUSING DAMAGE LIKE THIS IN THE
SOUTHERN ISRAELI TOWN OF
ASHKELON.
WHILE IN EAST JERUSALEM WHERE
THIS ALL BEGAN, PROTESTERS TOOK
TO THE STREETS THIS WEEKEND TO
COMMEMORATE NAKBA DAY OR THE
CATASTROPHE WHEN HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PALESTINIANS WERE
DISPLACED FROM THE HOLY CITY AND
OTHER AREAS DECADES AGO.
A TRAUMA JAD HAM AD SAYS HE'S
RELIVING.
ONE OF SIX PALESTINIAN FAMILIES
FACING EXPULSION FROM THEIR
HOMES BY JEWISH SETTLERS.
WITH THE PROTEST THIS MUST FEEL
VERY ACUTE TO YOU.
>> IT'S VERY, VERY HARD.
WE HAD THE FEELING BEFORE, AND
THEY ARE JUST -- WAKE US UP, YOU
KNOW.
TO MAKE US -- TO MAKE IT VERY,
VERY HARD TO US TO LIVE IN HERE.
>> Reporter: ARE YOU AFRAID
YOU'RE GOING TO BE EVICTED?
>> OF COURSE.
I HAVE KIDS.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO WITH
THEM.
>> Reporter: NOW THESE POSSIBLE
EVICTIONS IS REALLY ONE OF THE
MAIN REASONS WHY WE'VE SEEN THIS
LATEST ROUND OF VIOLENCE,
VIOLENCE WHICH A WEEK LATER IS
ONLY LIKELY TO CONTINUE.
GAYLE?